graduate school but for me it was really
Corporate America and being in that
competitive environment I thought it was
50 50 I thought I could do everything a
man could do I thought I could do it
until I was 65 until I hit the wall and
when you put yourself in that position
where you become the breadwinner it's
natural that you think that no you know
we're gonna do this and when I got
divorced my ex-husband actually said
well I thought you were driving this bus
really hard lesson for me so since the
divorce I've been in a long-term
relationship was kind of like a one
percent kind of guy which means for me
I've had to do a lot of work to change
from that 50 50 modern mindset to being
more of a traditional support system